because to magic a continent in which
the rights of effectivity embodied in
women and men could be considered a
fundamental part of democracy understood
in a large sense as the daily cultural
dimension such intent involves the
cultural discourse which today receives
no attention in the political arena of
Europe although I mean neither at the
continental nor the national level
although it does find the place in the
public sphere created by the feminist
discourse but this isn't somehow a
separate at the public sphere this
cultural dimension connects the public
and the private and reformulates both I
refer to a concept of public dimension
of feelings as theorized by thinkers
like Lauren Berlin dan dance activist
with an affirmation of Rights in the
private sphere and their reverberations
in the public one therefore a radical
rediscovery of the boundaries between
the two as well as between public and
private memories I would like to take as
a point of departure for what concerns
the cultural memory of emotions the
novel causing all Italy Carine or Italy
published by Madame de Stael
in 1807 after her trip to Italy but
under style was the noblewoman the
writer and intellectual born in the
second half of the 18th century she was
the daughter of the Minister for
finances of Louise 16 and her mother had
a salon in Paris so did she a very
important intellectual salon but then
because mode understand had the very
liberal ideas she was sent into
siyul by Napoleon when he establishes
authoritarian regime and therefore see
she established her new salon in her
castle at copy in Switzerland she was of
Swiss French origin and she travelled
widely through Europe this novel which
has been largely forgotten in comparison
with other works by might understand is
relevant to us because the central
figure is Karine a woman an artist of
great versatility excellent in many
fields endowed with many natural gifts
poetry painting singing dancing a
beautiful and generous woman who enjoys
a great success in the city of Rome
where she lives
she is actually born of an British
nobleman and Italian lady and she is the
archetype of the cosmopolitan woman
because she is she speaks many languages
the important European languages for the
cultural sphere at the time Italian
French German English and she is she is
actually at ease in these various
countries for what concerns our capacity
to interact Green has a sad story tragic
story her mother died when she was 10
and she lived in Florence for some years
with an aunt who then also died and her
father who had remarried with a Scottish
woman called her to Scotland in this
country this country is used by the
Bundys Carl styled to evidence the
difference in the bringing up of young
women and women because in this country
Karine experienced the harshness of an
education imposed by her stepmother
according to local customs which obliged
women to be educated only for marriage
devoted to a husband and a home
and then she had to flee to Rome and
left behind her beloved stepsister
Lucille who could not escape the destiny
of being educated only for the home this
story is the mirror of Madame de Stael
experience of being an exceptional woman
exceptional woman being but understands
herself objects to this expression
she thinks that many she thought that
many women could become so-called
exceptional ones if they were allowed to
develop freely so it's not that women
are exceptional someone is are
exceptional because of some gifts but
because they have been allowed so the
destiny is a mirror of a destiny of a
woman in a society that did not
recognize women's rights to education
into an honest independent life but
understand herself experienced the
suffering that such a women woman had to
face in love relationships with men who
preferred it less independent women her
love story would be the intellectual
measurement comes down who actually
married a housewife and they the whole
idea is that Corinne press accuse a
cultured and liberated woman in the free
and united Europe the dream that man
understand nourished with her group of
friends from various European countries
at the castling incopy the liberal ideas
of the author are transparent in the
novel for instance there is grey space
dedicated to the fact that Napoleon
looted the Italian works of art and
brought them to Paris and so it's not
only for her liberal ideas but also for
her conversation that napoleon disliked
this novel in particular is
mother understand the attitudes of her
pop are presented as too narrow and
limiting for Corinne especially in the
field of effective relationship
relationships so this is she's not
important for us because she represents
an exceptional intellectual woman but
because she represents the struggle of
women for the right to effectivity as a
therefore mum is a form of subjectivity
so this is the meaning of the fact that
she is loved in this novel by various
men from various different countries
European countries Italy France Germany
Britain of course this is a you know
this is a Eurocentric view and it's even
not only Eurocentric is Western Europe
centres it's a typical indictment
position and all of these men are
described by the author of the novel is
very limited in their views by narrow
national outlook they are very nice they
are the stereotypes of nationality study
French is frivolous and the Italian is a
general springs and and so on but Karine
is the only European she is in
comparison with these meanings
encapsulated in their nationalities she
has a wider outlook and she falls in
love reciprocated with a British
nobleman Lord an elven but he is afraid
of marrying such an independent woman
and chooses to follow his father
posthumous advise to marry instead
current stepsister Lucille in the course
of this dramatic experience Karine loses
all her creativity and ends up letting
herself died after having taught music
to her knees Lucille's and nervous
daughter this young woman very similar
to Corinne will continue a genealogy
women through her art and
the Europe the Karine prefigures has a
great cultural memory but also memory of
oppression and repression of exclusion
of many from the enjoyment of rights in
the public and the private spheres it is
a memory of repression of civic rights
by authoritarian regimes but what for
what concerns women also by democratic
regimes such as the British one a
marriage with Kareem is seen by her
lover the ordinary as a double
transgression to the law of the Father
and to the law of the fatherland a
betrayal of the customs of his country
which however is portrayed in the novel
as highly civilized in other respects
then for what concerns the cultural and
emotional condition of women
significantly it is a woman who is not
prey of the prejudices held by men that
can represent a different free united
Europe and becomes a figure for a
possible European memory at the same
time kareem story is a warning of the
terrible loss of memory that european
society has for a long time imposed on
women and their history corinne cannot
really live in the europe of her time
she must die because she is so much in
advance with respect to the society of
her age and the memory for which kareem
story constitutes a cultural foundation
is as I have said the tanks a memory
attentive to the sphere of sentiments a
memory of emotions as a basis for both
the public and the private spheres
concerning everybody in a in the daily
life historically the link between a
European sphere understood as public and
the private sphere has been established
by many Europeans perhaps the best-known
being
it is to him that we owe the expression
a Europe of sentiment understood as a
sense of belonging which is both
cultural and personal and tinted with
nostalgia for the past
however it was Ursula Hirshman who
generated the concept to pursue
management might not be very well known
she has become now in Europe she was
born I think in 1913 in Berlin from a
Jewish family and her brother was
advertisement they but Albert said he
lost one end in this country because his
ish man was written on anyway they both
had to flee from the lien because of the
analysis and went first to Paris and
then to Rome and birth Salah became very
active in the anti-fascist movement and
she also was active in the Federalist
movement so she participating in writing
the 1941 manifesto for for united Europe
which was not only an anticipation of
the European Union but actually it is
still much forward than the European
Union itself because it projected an
idea of justice and equality for all
newsmen insisted on the link between the
public and the private and on the
possibility of feeling at the same time
a subject of European Asst and of love
she created a group of Europeans women
some top-level women for Europe in 1975
in Brussels and this group group is
interesting because it was composed
largely of the wives of Europe
bureaucrats and these women first
unhappily in the role of white so they
chose the word farm which in French
means both women and wives to actually
expose the idea of the
only wives they wanted to be perceived
as protagonists of the European life Oh
having been militants but actually also
simply in terms of the agenda condition
there the memory that they transmit to
us however cannot help being subjected
to criticism it is true that I connected
the idea of love and the idea of Europe
but this there is still this connection
still had some element of subordination
subordination in the infecting the role
of wife and also some elements of
Eurocentrism they had they included in
their writings declaration such as that
they felt the European sisters of
migrant women and the wars in this sort
of declarations a type of what was
called in the cemetery zucchinies an
attitude of support for the
underprivileged which is not really
based in equality however their choice
to be identified for you with Europe in
the most difficult conditions and to act
consciously as European East has a value
for the construction of the memory of
Europe based on passion a passion that
connected the private and the political
and that involved always some type of
attraction the inter subjective nature
of the enterprise of sample Europe
contains positive aspects to be rescued
and elaborated together with a criticism
of its
anachronistic for us today aspects thus
in this sense if subjected to this real
abrasion their effort can become a part
of a memory for possible euros I will
now turn to the area of communicative
memory the communicative memory of
emotions taking my examples from the
research gender relationships in Europe
which was then supported by the European
Union in the year 2000 2004 and
connected five European universities
among which attract the Florence and
Copenhagen Budapest and Sofia this
research is ready known in to some
extent to the participants in my class
but I will just give some elements of it
to connect with the cultural memory of
emotions this research studied the oral
memories of women migrants from
Bulgarian Hungary to Italian and
attendance in their memory narratives
the sphere of effectivity was very
present sometimes in the come in
connection with the question of being
European in the Bulgarian interviews
meaningful replies to the questions in
Europe were given in correspondence with
contemporary political events but also
the basis of personal bonds the private
was present in a new sense of belonging
that could be arranged from some replies
for instance of the basis of the ancient
cell representation of women woman's
mother which seems to solve or overcome
the problematic nature of the European
rhetoric of unity
this is the case of a statement by a
Bulgarian woman claiming to be one of
the female ancestors of a new generation
of Europeans more often the love of the
couple is mentioned in the narratives of
the Bulgarian and Hungarian women who
give this as a reason for migration in
order to rejoin either a husband or a
boyfriend
the discourse of love emerges as a
constant element of these memories even
through the declarations of my ex
negativa
such as my goal was obviously she is
Bulgarian
my goal was obviously to see to learn to
visit I haven't met my great love as if
the imaginary around migration
necessarily included love in one way or
another in real life sometimes migration
induced a breakup and therefore this is
this memory is very strongly connected
with an imaginary an imaginary of love
there are important elements given also
however in the interviews about the fact
that even Democratic states like the
Netherlands practice a sort of invasion
of the private and intimate sphere by
obliging people who want to marry if
they are not on its territory if they
are not of that nationality to prove in
some way that they are actually love and
not contracting a so-called fake
marriage so there are these elements of
connection between interpenetration
between public and private in the
interviews
if flexible attitude emerges in the
sense of a capacity to move motivated by
love relationships at the end at the
same time by the wish to learn languages
find new jobs bridge cultural
differences love appears
in a certain sense to be a force pushing
towards the Continental dimension and it
is however paired with nationality
therefore it is an emotion that does not
rule out other emotions such as the
pride for one's nationalities or for
one's work for what concerns Europe they
interviewed with Bulgarians and the
Hungarians seem to confirm a simpler at
the simpler at a simpler level of
expression what the experience of family
op suggested tentative new ways of
feeling European are possible linked
with new developments in emotional life
capable of bringing the contribution of
the private into the public personal
memories offer instances of a love that
is a driving force in bridging cultural
differences one of the forces that move
people towards change at the same time
informed by previews and new loyalties
this approach is adequate to situations
undergoing changes since it is pragmatic
attentive to personal feelings and to
cultural traditions of different
countries also although this basis for a
new for for new forms of European Asst
can also be seen as frail and
contradictory in in this sense the
combination of the personal memories of
women migrants with the cultural
memories represented by Corrine through
the mediation of Pam problem up is
relevant because it is this combination
of different
cultural and communicated memories of
emotions that can create somehow the
image of new careens new cravings who
narrate the stories of migrations and
their own memories following like the
protagonist of Madame de Stan's novel
love bonds but unlike her claiming to be
able to find new ways of life that
accommodate their emotions although in
an often difficult and risky manner
therefore I see both continuity and
discontinuity between these different
memories cultural and communicative but
I see them converging to combine to
compose a complicated pattern of
possible memories of emotions and this
complication is in the sense that there
are many breaks in the memories of
Europe which are multiple not only in a
horizontal or synchronic sense but also
in a vertical or diachronic one there is
no continuous line of memory from
Aristotle to Maastricht as it is claimed
by those who all the view of an
essential European identity to be
promoted and defended by a cultural
fortress Europe and so there is not a
natural continuity between Madame de
Stael
or sulla Hirschman and the bulgarian
hungarian migrants but i think they can
be that bridges can be established by us
so i can go to the second part of my
talk as you might have guessed from what
I've been saying for many years I've
been engaged in the task of criticizing
Eurocentrism
from within believing that this task was
an urgent one in order to move the
post-colonial glance from external to
internal relations
and this included the attraction for the
so-called internet other the internal
other being one example of internal
other being in my recent work the Jewish
cultures of love in the Europe of the
20th century following the view that the
Jews represented for a long time the
internal other of Europe I also share
the conviction of a close link between
the conceptualization of the internal
other and of the external others so if
the reason internal other is because
there have been external others this was
evident for instance in the type of
racist discourses developed by NASA's
manned Italian fascism which put
together the Jews and Negroes precisely
the point of their in capability to
experience courtly romantic love a
supposedly European exclusive specialty
however and this is a historical
perspective but I also share Talal
Assad's conviction that in Europe today
Arabs are the present days jews in more
precise quotation from Talal Asad
he says nowadays in the West Arabs and
Muslims have to some extent replace the
Jews both as an undesirable element in
our society and as a symbol of the
insidious power of money all right so
all this is just to hint that some more
my work but I want to leave aside my own
work now and to switch from an inside
when I an outside critique of
Eurocentrism
and at the same time to operate that
change in the meaning of the expression
memory of Europe which I said is also
grammatical and syntactical in the sense
that until now I have spoken in as if
member of Europe meant the memory that
Europeans have of themselves of Europe
now I want to ask to transform Europe
not in a subject of memory but into an
object of memory who remembers Europe
and who remembers Europe means what is
remembered about Europe and about with
you about which Europe do people talk
remember it therefore I turn to ongoing
research done being done by young
scholars on the memory of the European
colonial heritage in the ongoing
diaspora of people from the whole world
that crosses the continent of these days
one reason for this choice is the
relevance that memories of colonialism
have today in the post-colonial Europe
very often with an insufficient
attention to it certainly so in my own
country Italy by post-colonial I mean a
type of glance type of gaze which takes
into account that the colonialism has
existed and has to a certain extent
inside the globe
and therefore is the premise to
globalization it's a form of
globalization so global and
post-colonial blends are linked strictly
to God
another reason for this switch of
attention from the internal to the
external other is that the external
other represented by the Jews has been
privileged the privilege in the memory
of the Shoah in creating making out of
it a screen memory that has contributed
to silence the experience of some other
internal others such as the wrong people
black Europeans homosexual but also very
much the memory of colonialism and
therefore I want to go I think that any
discourse on memory of Europe today must
be they must be taking into account the
memories of immigrants better defined in
academic terms as diasporic subjects but
also perhaps this is a word which has
which is very cryptic to many immigrants
themselves not that they always accept
the term migrants so it says I use the
term migrants as a shortcut but I know
it's not a very good choice but it is
the hey who bring to Europe the
awareness of its colonial past and
sometimes combine it with the decision
of being in some way and at least
partially European this second part will
be largely but not only centered on
living memories whether oral or written
they could be combined with cultural
memories but and I will I don't think we
have the time to go deep into that but I
will mention with which cultural
memories they can be combined and then
might eventually pick this topic up in
the discussion I'm thinking of memory
such as the ones about which Paul Gilroy
Guillory has written in black Atlantic
memories of black people from the United
States who decide to cross the ocean in
the opposite direction from opposite
today to the slave trade crossing the
Atlantic to Europe and with
rediscovering the value of the heritage
of Rights in Europe they have it is not
necessarily the practice and the
capacity of playing this heritage
against the racism in the United States
according to Paul Gilroy this recrossing
of the Atlantic toward Europe Germany
France Britain by people like w eb du
bois or richard wright or so on
developed is the double consciousness
and it is this double consciousness of
belonging not one belonging but a
multiple type of belonging which is at
the basis of the type of memory I'm
thinking of now for Europe as well but
now let us go to the living memories I
will start from the work of a young
researcher Leslie Hernandez Nova she's
from Mexico and she has been
interviewing peruvian women migrants to
the north italian region of Piedmont and
interpreting their memories she has
noticed that the narrations of peruvian
women migrants share is a central focus
of collective memory a strongly
emotional image of the conquista
considered as the beginning of colonial
relationships in the process of Union
and separation at the same time the
consciousness seen as the point of
encounter between various South American
countries and at the same time
the transversal line that connects this
territory with Europe this event has
left deep traces in their collective
memory and is the basis for the present
perceptions of Europe the collective
memory in oral terms the collective
memory of the conquista as they present
it owes much to cultural memory embodied
in historical filmic and literary texts
thus the migration to the European
continent is framed in a global
dimension and the consciousness
understood as a major step in the
process of unification of the planet but
also the beginning of displacement at
the world level the territorial sense of
belonging to Latin America which is
supply national inducing the Peruvian
woman's memories a perception of Europe
from a geo cultural perspective in this
perspective Europe is seen as a unified
space composed of many nations of
territories it's a it's a territory
sometimes seen as more United than it
really is since the migrants project the
unifying vision of Latin American
culture on the European case in many
narrations Italy is paying German in
Europe I mentioned is equivalent
although Spain maintains a prominent
role as a place where the migrants find
the roots of one of the languages the
interpretation proposed by Leslie
Hernandez is that the wider sense of
belonging developing on the basis of the
migration and coupled with the memory of
the computer produces a new form of
subjectivity this embraces both the
supranational sense of belonging to
Latin America in the possible sense of
belonging to Europe with some
limitations in the case of the second
there are in fact aspects of identity
which cannot be included in this second
sense of belonging
there is a sort of permanent laceration
already present in the memory centered
on colonial conquest oppression and
destruction the limits of the
identification as Europeans are to be
found in the suffering that living and
moving in Europe imply for the migrants
to the difficulties of all sorts that
they meet their return trips to Peru
strengthen the sense of double belonging
but at the same time also the
lacerations inside this sentiment when
back in the country of origin the
migrant hears her friends and relatives
who stayed behind expressed their
admiration and envy to her for having
chosen Europe where life is supposed to
be better than in the other country list
of destination the United States but she
the migrant woman keeps almost as a
secret the memory of her suffering in
Europe thinking that those who stayed
behind don't know what it is really like
no memory of Europe today can be built
without his multiple memories of
migrants which include often a
fragmented sense of the potential
belonging to Europe in other words
besides exploring the past to look for
forms of forgotten memories we must at
the same time explore the present to
find traces of the future the memories
of the word migrants that move across
Europe today evidence forms of conflict
for intersubjectivity understood as a
relationship between different cultures
through the past and the present their
cultures of mobility involve the
internalization of the migratory process
with emotions it entails emotion in the
larger sense and the love of the couple
that concur to constitute the migrants
memories
the eating areas of the migrants towards
and through the European continent
operate the process of D territorial
ization which does not merely
problematize the traditional border
borders of Europe is fixed but also
brings to new recognition various forms
of multiple attachments to more than one
place inside and outside the continent
practices of mobility inside and from
outside outside Europe a central for the
redefinition of memories in the
post-colonial global perspective the
historical presence of mobile subjects
and their contribution to the
circulation and Cup of cultures and of
practices challenge the Eurocentric
racial and national assumptions of a
homogenous white and male European
public sphere and identity by placing
Europe in a new relationship with the
rest of the world as well as with its
internal margins in the course of this
process living memory assumes a
post-colonial dimension not in the sense
of a factual testimony but thanks to the
symbolic value of his message this is
why I would like now to go to a
post-colonial memory which is being
constructed in Italian by writers of
Ethiopian Eritrea and in Somali origin
Italian colonialism in those areas
lasted from 1882 to 1941 it is
interesting that the great majority of
these new writers are women in a process
relatively new for Italy and closely
linked in his rowing dimension with the
emigration from the south of the world
to Italy in the very last decades on
this topic I take my examples as well
from the work of young researchers were
studying post-colonial Italian
literature on the basis of published and
unpublished autobiographical novel moral
or ASCII another
young researchers has found that during
the first phases of the African
migration to Italy the migrants had an
image of Europe that coincided with that
of of Italy while in the last 20 years
Europe started to be conceived as a
unitary bloc within which it became
possible to choose among various
countries of destination including Italy
this change in perception testifies an
enlargement of the vision of Europe and
the redefinition of the image of Italy
as well as a modification of memory in
respect to the relationship between
Europe and its Nations at the same time
the memory of Italian colonialism
remained central for instance Laura's
keys analysis confirms the role of
memories of met Asajj and of Madame Otto
Madame Otto was the cohabitation of
African women called Madame and Italian
man mostly military in the 1930s this
practice was declared illegal by the
fascist government in 1937 it was a
crime their memories of abused women's
bodies have been transmitted through
generations from the basis of oral
narrations that connect the past and the
present bodies convey a monastic trace
of colonialism and the very language
chosen for writing down these
transmitted memories Italian is such a
trace because it brings within itself
the memory of colonization at the same
time it joyce corresponds to the
decision to break the silence and turn
upside down the imposed heritage
thus the transmitted memory of madame
otto takes a new light in a European
context and so does the role of the
stories of immigrants women in this
context there are many of these
autobiographies in novel
and I cannot quote them all but I will
quote one by Shirin ramdux Ali Fazal
analyzed by another young researcher
Gabriela prana because she gives central
relevance to the transmission of
memories from her childhood in
Somaliland and this memories exist on
the urban landscape of Mogadishu which
is marked by the traces of colonialism
in science and names and in an African
country these signs and names are all in
Italian but in Tarot via roma squalor
Regina Anunnaki sadistic record and it
is this memory which is at the heart of
the transmission of memories that they
hold they also moved to Italy in 1971
and she intends to transmit this memory
to her children thus to perform an
intersubjective gesture between
generations in this case - the language
adopted for the transmission of memory
is the site of an imposed
intersubjectivity which is prolonged
prolonged in an inter subjectivity
experience in Italy often conflictual
with elements of paternalistic
benevolence xenophobia and sometimes
racism language in hybridizing the
stories of the past is connected with
memory it is itself a form of memory a
form of memory that mixes the culture
and the communicative as Lydia Court the
author of the book the bottle ultra the
voice of the other woman has written
language becomes a place of encounter
between refugees exiled migrants giving
rise to a different intersubjectivity
that transforms the memory of the past
into a stance towards the transcultural
present
such memory is in fact the result of a
negotiation with various epochs places
and cultures I am concluding the Europe
that is remembered by the diasporic
subjects across the continent today is a
Europe of oppression and exclusion of
destruction and his women yet at the
same time the migrants are able to
express new forms of subjectivity which
include a contradictory effectivity
towards Europe an emotional investment
which comprises but is larger than the
private labs and which can contribute to
create new senses of belongings
belonging while modifying the existing
ones as Derrida said one can feel
European among other things and among
others namely on the side of the other
I have insisted on the multiplicity of
memories for Europe of women and men of
native Europeans and of diasporic
subjects in oral and written form forms
but it cannot be an undifferentiated
multiplicity within this multiplicity I
proposed to carve itineraries that
correspond to certain priorities and
operate resolute choices priorities are
dictated I believe by the imagination of
future possible Europe's which add a
touch of utopia to the existing Europe
on the basis of memories transmitted
from the recent and remote past of the
continent to therefore I insist on the
link between memory on one side and
utopian imagination or the other in
order to make choices within the
multiple memories of Europe's Europe the
expression
in memory of Europe should always be
understood as a phrase in which Europe
can be bought a subject and an object in
the nub double sangs of remembering
herself is Europe is symbolized by a
woman and of being by a female figure
and of being remembered by those who
were considerate for others